[Music]
potted up and ready to go there it is
ready to go welcome to the show big day
today on the show big day a lot of stuff
to cover yeah but first and
foremost I didn't sleep well last night
let's spend the first half hour
discussing that how was your Uber this
morning you know I we can talk about
that too that's the first break's going
to be I didn't sleep very well what my
Uber was this and drafty Windows I've
heard I have that on the C sheet good
the drafty Windows we're going to get
into but that's the second half that's
the teaser okay I didn't mean to get too
early on that are you coming to the
Patrice benefit tonight oh I didn't even
know that was tonight it was tonight
yeah I don't think so we got nothing
else to do I mean I'll probably be busy
tonight why what are you doing what Jess
gave birth you know over the weekend
what yeah and I mean I was I told you I
think and it was put on social media
it's not you don't have to act surprised
by it off for the radio I was
actually just like oh you guys just
eavesdropping into two buddies having
the conversation for the first time hey
did did you tell your mom yet no she's
but she listens to the show so should
find out so it's no problem yeah how you
doing how you feeling man it's it's it's
big news yeah good it it was uh I mean
you know he's healthy so everything's
good we went in uh Jess was supposed to
get induced on Sunday night because he
was like like that's why it was
stressful going away last weekend
because it was technically after Jess
was due but we had gone to the doctor
and he had he really didn't think the
baby was coming that weekend if we
thought that the baby was coming that
weekend it would have been a different
story but we really didn't think the
baby was coming and it wasn't so but we
kind of figured it would come like on
Monday or Tuesday of last week or
something but it just didn't and so we
scheduled a thing and said all right
they're going to induce her on Sunday
night and on Saturday night so I was
thinking because the weekend before
because everybody's like oh make sure
you stuck up on your sleep before it's
okay thanks like I I'll make sure that I
Bank all the sleep hours people make
those remarks yeah because I usually you
know my lifestyle is conducive to
getting just eight hours of sleep every
night you know that's what I usually get
like everybody just sleeps so much until
they have kids right nobody's busy you
know what I mean but but still I didn't
sleep like last weekend because I was
travel I was only in Phoenix for
whatever 26 hours so there wasn't like
I'd sleep two hours on the plane I came
to the show blah blah blah but I was
like it's okay because this
weekend I'll sleep and then you know
it'll be a couple nights but on Friday
night I had I went to bed late and then
had to wake up early to do something
with the dog and I said well not
like got to do all that stuff before the
kid
comes do something was that do you mean
do it you were going to do it with the
dog yeah
ew yeah just just get on your hands KNE
let the dog Mount you one more time
that's it yeah Jess I know you can't go
out but the peanut butter was supposed
to be delivered we only we have a a
small window here um but so then I was
like it's okay on Saturday I'll sleep
and then we can wake up whatever because
we weren't going to get induced until
Sunday night so you're going to call the
hospital like 5:00 and it's so weird the
way they do it cuz you'd think they
would be able to plan it but you have to
they said just call it like five or six
call the hospital and see if there's any
beds available and it's like on the
Saturday no on Sunday night like right
before you come so if there's beds now
then come and then you'll have your baby
and if there's no beds now you come
later we'll do it later it's like it's
like either this thing of like a mediacy
that you see in all the movies where
you're like pack the back or it's like H
just call ahead and see are they more
casual than you would have expected them
to be about the birth yeah yeah until I
mean when it's time it's time and
everything just Springs in into action
but until it's there's a lot of time
before it's time you know and they tell
you just if you go into labor just stay
home like don't come to the hospital
just stay home for a while you don't
need to jump in the car you don't need
oh my God my water broke if we get
pulled over it's okay the cops will
understand we have to go 70 M an hour
like they're like stay home as long as
you can because you'll be in the
hospital for hours otherwise it's
uncomfortable so but we're just going to
call ahead and get induced in the whole
thing but then what time did you go well
the problem was uh on Saturday I went to
bed at like midnight whatever 12:30 and
then at 1:30 justess woke me up she's
like Sam I'm having
contractions and I was like what and so
like you have to time them on an app so
you know when it's or whatever yeah I
mean you don't really need an app you
can just write it down but it's a lot
easier to just hit your phone when
you're half asleep so like she went into
labor at like 1:30 in the morning on
Saturday night into Sunday how far apart
were the contractions uh I think at
first it was a couple minutes and then
it was like 5 minutes 5 minutes is what
it was is that mean it's time to go no
it doesn't necessarily like there's all
these factors like but we just kept
having to call the doctor who was on
call it's like 2 o'clock in the morning
there's a doctor's 24 they do 24-hour
shifts so like there's always there's a
doctor that you can call and they'll be
there and blah BL but they get to the
phone when you're calling for this yeah
yeah like you leave a message and then
they call you back within two minutes
like it's quick they're they're good and
so she was going it was for I thought
she was like just kind of whatever like
like I she was having pains or whatever
and she thought it was this but it
wasn't really just because nothing had
been happening there have been a few
false alarms but nothing had been
happening and the baby was so overdue I
figured it was just not that just what
it was going to be were you hoping that
she wasn't at that hour of the night
going into Contra were you hoping that I
was like let's yeah let's hope it's gas
it's 1:30 now if by 2:30 the gas Settles
we can all just go back to sleep and
I'll sleep till like 11:00 that' be
perfect yeah but the gas didn't settle
no it didn't no no she just kept having
her her gassy pains or whatever it was
so uh uh so we it was until like 6
o'clock in the morning that they just
kept going and going and then it was
were you up with her the whole time or
did you doze back off I was dozing yeah
I dozed back off like at one point she
was sitting on the floor because laying
down wasn't comfortable anymore and I
was like okay well I just lie down and
and do the app but like we were talking
and everything and then I like was like
okay it's you know 4:00 a.m. let's just
keep doing this and then I looked at the
clock again and it was like it's 5 I
like for an hour I snoozed for an hour
and she was like it's it's fine like she
didn't even want to talk at that point
she's in a lot of pain she was in pain
yeah yeah after a few hours it was like
she didn't even want to deal with it she
didn't want to talk she didn't want to
have any conversations nothing so O So
at 6 she was like Sam go take the dog
out to pee and then we got to go we we
like they're going to tell us it's too
early but we just got to go how far from
the hospital are you it's like uh I
don't 30 minutes or so it's a ride yeah
so that's what I did and we you know put
the dog in the crate and I was going to
call my parents and pick them up when we
got there but we went to the hospital
and we drove slowly because then she's
like in pain and she's nauseous and like
the whole thing so like if I to theal no
she did when we got to the hospital and
she did before but not in the car right
um and you know and you don't know like
fluid's going to leak out of what end
and everything it's a very messy towel
down on the seat yeah I would have too
yeah definitely you have to break I'll
pull
over she put the towel down on the seat
just because I mean we drove her car she
was like I'm not going to [__] up my
passenger seat because of this yeah so
so she put it down and uh and we went
and she was in a lot of pain like she
wasn't even she didn't want to talk she
didn't want to open her eyes like it was
just like just uncomfortable and it's
tough like that's the the toughest part
for a guy cuz like you don't really do
anything except support but like you
don't like to see your wife like that
I've never seen her that pained or
uncomfortable and that's where it's like
it's like this sucks you know but so we
were PR apparently you didn't look at
her while she was exchanging
vows yeah no that that's that's that's
the overwhelming sensation of
disappointment in her eyes that's that's
different that's not as physical that's
that's that's realizing her dreams are
never going to come true that's that's
when you realize Cinderella and Prince
Charming it's just a fairy tale so you
you can't there's nothing you can do for
her you just you can just drive are you
trying to say anything to her I just
said I'm like Jess just if you want me
to speed up just say the word if you
want me to slow down say the word like
I'm telling her like y at me do whatever
whatever just get it out as quickly as
possible and so she just be like slower
and like I'd slow down or whatever and
that was it but so we got there and we
had all our stuff but nobody it was like
you know wasn't even 700 in the morning
yet on Sunday so there was not that many
people working at the hospital the
nurses were there and everything but we
just went up to the Maternity Ward and
like you have to call because they won't
let people in like you have to pick up
the phone so they can open the door
and like almost like jail except with no
you know you just pick the phone up and
the and the nurse the reception picks it
up and we're like yeah we're here we
need to have a room to give birth in
they were like okay yeah you can go into
room too there was a room available yeah
there was a room open so we just went in
there and the nurse came in and did the
whole thing and you know she was
thinking about doing it natural she had
to feel better being there like knowing
all right I'm at the hospital the trip
is done I'm here and they immediately
put a thing on you to hear the baby's
heartbeat and do the whole thing cuz
that's important cuz I mean I think I
said before that a couple years ago we
have been trying to get pregnant and we
lost it and like there is nothing on the
planet worse than getting that heartbeat
monitor set up and just an empty room
you know what I you just don't like just
no sound and you're like oh like and the
doctor has to come in and be like look
and tell you what happened and it's it's
the worst so after that happens
especially because then like you know
nobody talks about that stuff so it
becomes especially for like Jess or any
women that go through that like people
just don't talk about how often that
happens right so they all feel like
alone and they have this sense of loss
and like you just realized this thing
and you were planning and it's not going
to happen so like it's why no one says
it till like what there's three months
is that they cut off where you start to
say it yeah and we waited until like
Jess was showing and people were like
could you just say what's going on the
kid was a week old before Sam told
anybody so
so so yeah I mean so hearing the
heartbeat is like very reassuring just
throughout the whole process just you
know everything's okay and you know
you're in the hospital and you're good
yeah yeah but so they were like with her
and stuff and and after a few few hours
she realized she was doing the epidural
and and
like I get why people don't want it I
don't know why they don't I think it's
because just like the the the idea of
like I want to just experience that's
the way you're supposed to but Jess
thought she didn't want it and then she
got it and immediately and it doesn't
drug you up it just makes you feel
better and immediately she was like I
don't know why anybody wouldn't do that
it's Insanity it's like I want to do it
natural good go stand in the woods then
that's how they used to do it what's
wrong with you right get the epidural
yeah yeah she got it and it was
literally within moments the person that
I knew returned she was not she was not
I didn't know who she was before she got
the epidural like she wasn't talking she
was just in pain and discomfort and
nauseated and just the whole just as
uncomfortable as I've ever seen anybody
and then they put the epidural and
that's like it's not a great process to
watch happen how do they do it CU it's
literally I mean it's it's a it's a
needle that they put in between your
your spine like in between your
vertebrae or whatever it is so they can
hit the right nerve and you know Hur
when they give it to her I think so she
did they numb it before the epidural yes
yes but I mean she was a champion about
it but like she had her head down and
everything and they make you like they
make they told me after why they do it
but there's a stool so they make her sit
on the bed right she's sitting on the
edge of the bed and then they put the
epidural in from behind obviously so
they make her you have to like Arch her
back almost like a cat you know showing
its spine and then they figure out the
spot and they put it in but like I uh uh
they put me on a stool sitting on a
stool in front of her so I'm face to
face with her and they said they
specifically do that like they make all
husbands do that because they pass out
they said all the time like that's why
you have to sit down you can't be
standing where in this hospital when
they see when you see the epidural that
you husbands pass out yes yes is it just
a giant how big is the needle well it's
it's a big needle and then they put a
catheter in to the spine so they can
just throughout the entire process like
for it's it's me yeah except into your
spine wow so what's what's the pro
what's the part that makes the husband
pass out just seeing the needle go into
the spine I think the injection no he's
in front of her you're in front of her
oh sorry Adan hold on but hold on I I
didn't plan on such a ludicrous question
hold
on you're standing behind her in front
no no no they make you ask about the
conception yeah I'm talking about EP
that's the case well she was technically
upside down and uh she was uh no you
have to they make you sit on a stool in
front of her so you can't see it so you
can't see it and so you're sitting not
standing wow because it happens I guess
a lot and and it what like I could see
just like realizing what was going on
behind her and it's not something like
it's not like getting a shot it takes a
couple of minutes like there's you have
to numb it and you have to inject it you
have to put this in and it's like it's a
complicated thing there's a reason why
like anesthesia ologists are just
doctors that just do is that who does
that the anesthesiologist yeah like
that's and they're the only ones who do
that and blah blah blah but it's like
yeah it's this hole they have to put
plastic down on your back and do it's a
big process to amazing husbands pass out
at that part I wonder if that if they
pass out at that because of that
procedure or that's like oh no here it
is it's happening that's true too it's
probably nerves combined too plus like I
mean you have to also realize that both
of us but Jess specifically like is
going through all this stuff and we
haven't slept
right so you know that sort of like how
your nerves are like you're super
sensitive to everything when you haven't
slept you're irritable and you just want
to like just yell and cry and and do
everything when you're not sleeping
what's all this discomfort plus not
sleeping how are you doing when you sat
down on the chair did you feel like
nauseous at all or like woozy no I
wasn't nauseous but I got it like I was
watching her like I there was just a
natural instinct kicked in where like I
wanted to stop what was happening I just
realized that this is like awful I could
never imagine having this done to me and
I wanted to stop it from happening to
her so was it was how how long is she in
pain while they're doing the
epidural
well while they the epidural process is
probably like I don't know it's like
three or three or four minutes probably
but you know I mean imagine if getting a
shot took three or four minutes you know
what I mean like it takes it's it feels
long and it maybe it's not even 3 or 4
minutes but it just felt felt long and
then but it's also like you're in as as
a woman like you're in so much pain and
discomfort that it's almost like this
thing in my back isn't bothering me one
more [__] thing that will fix
everything else go ahead yeah I've got a
person that's been just putting its
entire body weight on the top of my
vagina for nine months isolate
that so so and and literally like within
a few minutes it was like all the life
is back in her face and she's able to
have conversations again and she's just
back yeah it's smart to do it I think I
don't know what the advantage to Natural
is other than you feel a lot more pain I
think it's just just that idea of like I
had natural birth yeah natural birth and
it's my connection with baby and and
this is the way it was intended to be
and blah blah blah and like I told Jess
I was like Jess like God intended for
you to feel when the dentist drills a
cavity God intended for that to really
hurt but you get Novacane right I'm like
just just make it comfortable like this
is especially when it's like this is
going to be a long process yeah and uh
so she got it and after she got it like
she wasn't like you know it's not like
being at Disney world but she was way
more comfortable how long were you there
before she actually got the shot at the
epidural
um we were probably in the probably like
3 or 4 hours in the hospital plus the 5
hours at home okay so three or four
hours there already so cuz like
technically she was like around 1:00 in
the morning is when labor started okay
so but then we were at the hospital
starting at 6 so yeah we got around 10
or 11 in the morning I think so what
happens she gets the shot she's now
feeling better you're sitting there with
what are you doing are you getting
something to eat or are you just talking
to her um yeah I'm just hanging out with
her like at that point she she really
got it so she could sleep a little bit
and so like I was kind of dozing a
little bit and she was in and out of
sleep because she couldn't sleep even
when she knew it was going to be a while
she couldn't sleep cuz she was in too
much pain and plus you're anxious I'm
sure right but once she got that thing
done she could sleep at least like for a
little while does that knock you out at
all no it's just you're not like you're
in too much pain to sleep otherwise okay
and you're nauseate and the whole thing
could she feel it can you feel your legs
after you get an epidural can you still
feel your body W they put it in they do
it in such a way where you can still
feel them like because that was
something and they could give you a lot
more so you didn't feel them but they
they figure out the amount so that you
can feel your legs I mean she's still
like I still had to help her moving what
like her leg like her legs would fall
asleep or whatever but like you can
still and that way you can still push
and you can still do everything that you
need to do okay but yeah so she was
there uh for a while and then nothing
like like she wasn't progressing the way
you're supposed to not in like a harmful
way but just like you know your body has
to get ready for a [__] watermelon to
come out of your vagina and it wasn't
happening I think that's the medical
term yeah you're right they don't say
vagina they use the CW
but trying to get a watermelon out of
this
cup I just don't want to throw a bunch
of medical jargon at the Lost listeners
that's what the doctor said we got to
get a watermelon out of this [__] what
are we doing imagine imagine if he did
that for some levity and it bombed you
might to have that watermelon fished out
of your [__]
Cricket doc timing like what you what
you doing J just look at me did he just
say what are do out of my [__] yeah did
he say fish it this is a magical moment
comes comes in with with a fishing pole
just for a prop yeah get
laugh I tried it guys I tried I don't
know yeah sorry um but we uh uh uh but
it wasn't it wasn't uh so she wasn't her
body wasn't progressing the way it
should and then they you they give you
medication to kind of help your body
start to progress but then they have to
pay attention to how the baby is
responding to the medication and to the
contractions and all that and like if
the baby they don't [__] with the baby's
heart rate at all if there's any sort of
Dipping then they just stop whatever's
happening you know what I mean like like
they don't they don't take any chances
with that and so so that's what was
happening so like the we couldn't really
but the heart rate was dropping a little
not like to the point where it was scary
at all but to the point where they were
like we can't give you more of this drug
no chances right because you because it
might it might it could be a problem and
we just don't want to risk it and I was
like okay but but without if we don't do
that there's literally this is as
healthy as as this can get you're
totally fine it was like great but at
some point it was like so like 5 o in
the afternoon wow on Sunday we are we
were still there your whole Sunday
wasted I hope you were pissed yeah and
it was a beautiful day too it was
absolutely stuck in that room it was
ridiculous wow that's I didn't realize
that long yeah yeah so it's like 5:00 in
the afternoon and they were like we
might just have to do C-section here and
she was like I really don't want to she
just wanted a natural birth you know
vaginal birth and uh and they're like
all right she was like can you give me
more time like she would have sat there
for three days like as long as you kept
the epidural in her if that's what it
took she would have been fine but since
the baby was already like almost two
weeks late they're not they didn't there
were some doctors that wanted to get it
out before you know I mean they just
don't because there's only so much
nutrients or whatever you can't keep a
baby in you just indefinitely sure so uh
uh so they were like yeah you can't so
they were like uh uh what I'm just
thinking the idea of a like a the
toddler toddler he's PR I just love him
in there shoving little shoes in
there a little baseball hat
yeah we got him a catcher M this
year yeah just trying to put stuff up
there yeah little little things that
make Ting link noises
yeah you're just squeezing formula up
there it's not enough anymore so we just
it's his home he loves it he he won't
leave no and I love him in there my mom
probably would have kept me in there
until I was like four years old
absolutely four she'd be here right now
she'd be here right now with her legs up
on the console and a microphone of her
[__] there's that nice cousin Brucey
Echo
effect so uh so we're doing the thing
and they're like you know this is way
the way it's going and she goes uh that
she doesn't want to do it that way and
so the nurse came
in and said well we can try some new
positions like some like just laying on
different positions to see how the baby
responds to it and blah blah blah could
they see the kid was facing the right
way uh yes it was facing down yeah they
checked that in the ultrasound before
like they're supposed to flip at some
point like at the eight Monon or 7 month
I don't know what at what point but yeah
so it was it was facing down like you're
supposed to um
but so so they put her in a bunch of
different positions and they gave her
like a couple hours so it's like it's
like 6 6 o' 6:30 something like that and
they were like we got to do this we got
to we like this isn't happening and and
you haven't your position you haven't
changed you know so we got to we got to
uh get baby out of there and so that's
what we did so we went and did the
C-section and that was that was tough
cuz it's real surgery I mean it's it's
like
I guess vaginal bursts are tough too I
wouldn't know but it's you know they
have to give her more drugs it justess
hates drugs you know what I mean she
doesn't she's one of those people that
like panics when you you know just like
the loss of control or everything the
same way I would like you you start to
just panic and feel uneasy plus you're
exhausted and and the whole thing so but
she we did the C-section and I was she
worried about scarring cuz it's
apparently it's not that bad now
compared to the way it used to be you
can hardly see I mean it was a thought
but she knew that like yeah they they
cut way low and way small and that's
it's not a big deal anymore but uh and I
mean the benefit is it takes 45 minutes
like and you're done oh it's faster way
faster oh yeah yeah yeah I mean it takes
it takes there's another benefit we all
know it takes yeah it takes no time we
said C-section what was that noise the
husband was jumping for
joy yeah oh how long would it take
coming out uh I mean it depends it could
take you know hours you never know like
some people have to like just push for a
long time um so this is much faster are
you in the room when this is happening
yeah so like they but they have a whole
process like I had to put on Scrubs you
know some idiots too because I posted on
Instagram the picture of me just just a
photo of my shoes on with scrubs on as
if I was showing off my shoes but I was
obviously wearing scrubs and
like the point was to say this is
happening you know what I mean I was
being I was being cute yeah right I'll
say you are but a lot of people just
thought I was wearing ugly pants or they
were making fun of it or I was like what
are you guys doing like they were like
what are those
UFOs or like would you get a job in an
old folks home I'm like you're not
following along they understand no no no
they didn't but uh but yeah I guess I
was being vague anyway so sure good on
them to yeah yeah kick me in the [__]
balls but so we they prep the room they
put me in Scrubs they prep the room they
prep her and I go in like after all
that's done and they have a big blue
sheet and I'm over by her head so I'm
not seeing anything yes but she's like
all she's drugged up but she's still
fully conscious she's not loopy she just
can't feel anything below like her neck
or whatever are you nervous at this
point um yeah yeah nervous yeah
definitely cuz you're nervous for Jess
because you don't want to see your loved
one have surgery just because weird [__]
happens and then also this is like let's
get the baby out so you're now worried
about the health of both people yeah um
and you have to be that like person that
like I don't know how to be I don't know
what you're supposed to say in that
scenario that's comfortable like do I
just talk about something else cuz to me
I feel like if somebody was trying to
talk to me about like what happened on
Monday Night Raw while my insides were
being taken out I'd be like why you
talking to me about wrestling right now
now please tell me that's what you
talked about we all know what's
happening no I didn't BR you would have
been my idol if I was like so I found
out the release date on those sneakers I
don't know if I told you
earlier but yeah like she goes like uh
she asked the anesthesiologist she was
like are you sure that uh I can't feel
anything and he was like oh yes before
the surgery even starts they test
something on you without telling you to
see if you can feel it or not and the
pain that you would feel with that make
surgery seem like a breeze I mean it's
medieval what they do to test you and
she was like well what do they do and he
was like I'm not going to tell you cuz
he didn't want to freak her out oh wow
and we never found out he left I left
the room early CU they you know walk you
out of the room and he she said you know
she was all loopy by the end of it so he
said that they never you you know we
never found out I wonder if that's real
or if he's just saying that I don't know
I have no idea maybe yeah maybe with Dr
Steve is probably the guy to ask he
would know um yeah I'm sure he's botched
a bunch of
those yeah he used to he used to deliver
babies but then they're like you know
what maybe you should work in hospice
that seems to be your special absolutely
it seems to be the direction it goes
right after that
so so you you're in there for the actual
C now that there's the sheet up and and
you're sitting she up so I don't see it
at one point she like looks over at me
she's like Sam and she's like she's very
calm about it she almost it was a joke
she goes I just felt them put my guts on
my thigh cuz they have to literally take
your insides out no out of your stomach
take the baby out and then put your
insides back in oh my God you probably
shouldn't see that no no no no no no I
didn't and I didn't Peak I didn't I
didn't peek over the curtain like and
and when you leave because I have to
leave before they're done like tell you
when to leave and just wait I guess
sterility I don't know why but the
anesthesiologist was like Sam like like
he's like all right Sam you can go and
then he was like wait Sam he's like just
look forward on your way out just look
forward do not turn your head because
the curtain is just right so Jess can't
see so you walk right past it so if I
had turned my head I would have seen
everything I didn't look did you no I
did not I decided not to do you think
some husbands pass out at that moment oh
yeah oh yeah God damn it I told him not
to look [__] Punk oh No Just bleeding
out of his ear cuz his head hit the
floor so are you there when the baby
comes out yes so and that's a pretty
emotional cool thing that like you just
hear like cuz you don't hear and and and
like they're doing whatever they're
doing but like you can smell like you
know that smell when you're getting a
cavity drilled and like it's you know
that it's like rotting smell no no no
not the rotting smell the drilling smell
like when they're Drilling and and it's
hot it smells hot it's like like smell
of surgery yeah you could smell that and
Jess was like they're soldering me right
now and the doctor and the
anesthesiologist was like they're not
soldering you and Jess was like I can
smell it they're soldering me that
closing her and when she goes like and
when she goes like soldering she was
like she didn't believe the
anesthesiologist at all she was like
they put my guts on my thigh just now
and the anesthesiologists was like well
you know uh they also have a tool that's
like a bag that pushes air so so they
have that too and that feels the same
way and she was like so is that what
they put on my thigh and the
anesthesiologist was like yeah and she
looked at me and she goes that's not
what they put
on I don't believe him um and so yeah so
like you know they're doing this and
then you like and the anesthesiology is
like okay we should be he should be
coming out in five minutes okay we're
about we're only a couple minutes away
okay it's going to happen really soon
and then like you just kind of hear like
something make like a little squeaky
noise and then you hear the baby cry and
you look up and the thing is there and
you're like you're like oh my God like
that's and he's healthy and he's like I
mean he's blue when he comes out you
know right and you just wait and pray to
God that Oxygen's going to get in his
lungs and it does did they spank they
like do the smack or they don't do that
anymore they didn't not with this one I
don't know if it's protocol or not but
they I mean he was he they got him
crying he started crying when he got out
so they didn't have to right um and you
know and then they they set him up and I
could walk over and see him right away
while Jess was getting worked on and cut
the cord and do that whole deal so they
immediately wrap him with something or
is he naked or they wrap him up
immediately to keep him warm he's naked
at first and they got to clean him oh
they do yep and then uh and then they
weigh
him and we had I mean godamn how much is
the baby way it's a good thing that we
we went the way we went yeah cuz when
the baby came out like it was like there
was an audible
whoa when the baby came out cuz it was 9
lb 3 o which is big for a baby that's a
beast especially since Jess is 5T tall
oh my she's tiny wow congratulations to
the dad whoever he is
Jess is like Jess is like oh that's so
weird cuz neither of us are specifically
big people and I was like Jess maybe you
don't point that out like maybe just let
me let me just not let it go on said oh
congratulations congratulations cuck
boy 9B 3 o is a massive kid and part of
that is because it was in the in the
womb for so long sure W I told
myself but uh yeah so that's it was it
was a big guy and
you got to cut the cord and this little
blood splatter comes out when you cut it
and then how far down do you cut like
right above the belly not like right
above because they like I don't know
they they they Clos pin it off or
something he still got like a little bit
on it and I think that they everybody
says that comes off and you're supposed
to freak out when it comes off but uh uh
uh like just above that they said I did
a great job so I'm sure did um did you
guys eat the placenta mhm yeah yeah we
just like hey pass it over here just raw
good
nutrients you don't want a piece no I
don't you wouldn't want to try a
placenta uh a placenta slider no I
wouldn't did you say was your mom making
hats out of it no we saved it though no
yeah yeah Jim I have more special
cookies you really did save it we did
why why did you save it Jess wanted to I
don't know wanted to yeah yeah so it's
saved I think she's going to do
something with it I don't know
um yeah and then uh yeah somebody comes
and picks it up like there's a person
who that's their placenta specialist and
they come like you call them right after
they're like okay I'm coming you just
hand them the placenta this doctor was
so funny I heard I overheard him like
the uh the nurse was like we're going to
do this and then we're going to put the
placenta here and and we can place it
here blah blah blah and he just looked
her and he was like I'm not taking it
home like what are you talking to me
about the placenta for I don't give a
[__] like it's your problem I don't care
he's just so dismissive he was like I
just overheard him he's like well I'm
not taking it home cuz he's like I I
don't care what you do he care what you
did with it no no we're like just don't
throw it out okay and he was like yeah
fine then they like he like just don't
talk to me about it anymore yeah he was
done yeah over um yeah and then they had
to give Jess uh more drugs because she
started to feel stuff sure a little
discomfort yeah so like they pumped her
in and that was she didn't like that cuz
she started getting really loopy so wa
the baby is born they wash the kid real
quick they weigh him how long until both
of you you're holding him or she's
holding him
um I was able to they gave him to me
right away like they wrapped him up and
they gave they were like here you go and
I was able to hold like in the surgery
room and then I brought him over to Jess
CU she couldn't hold them obviously but
I brought him over to Jess and put him
put them like face to face and and and
that whole thing are you crying I I
wasn't sobbing but there might have been
some some uh a little some some moisture
that I just just when you hear that
first cry yeah yeah yeah like all right
it's done there was I'll say there was a
slight reminder that I was a human being
like there was like okay there's
something in there there's something in
this deep dark soul that qualifies as
human right and then then that was that
it went away yeah yeah then it went then
it went back to well he's going to be a
wrestler if he's if he's if he's 9B 3 o
yeah yeah he's going to be a [__] uh
you know he's going to be a very big boy
he's going to be two before he can kick
my ass yeah that's when at that moment
he stands up to Dad yeah yeah like the
original Superman when he picks the car
up yeah um but yeah so then uh uh yeah
then we uh we did that and I left and it
takes a little while to you know put
Jess's [__] back in her stomach and oh
you leave while they do that yeah yeah
and and fix her up and then
like it's surgery
right there's
[__] seven people in the waiting room
it's like 11:00 at night 10:30 at night
and everybody showed up I was like I
don't know like I was having that's like
I had to text people during the day and
be like ah hold off like we're just
seeing what's up like Jess is
uncomfortable and like everybody just
came anyway and so like the waiting room
was just full of my family and her
family mom dad come of course they did
and her mom and dad came her but they
divorc so her stepdad came too and then
her sister came and her sister's
boyfriend and it's just like everybody
sure and I was like oh my God like I'm
trying to I'm trying to process this
Jess is looped out of her mind and her
stomach was just cut open there's a baby
over here like what are yall doing here
you didn't want to entertain everybody
no no but they all needed to be a part
of it all of them understandable and so
I was like okay I was like uh you should
have announced Jess and I decided to see
other
people yeah so so while Jess is getting
fixed up I walked out and into the
waiting room they didn't let me wear my
scrubs in the movies you know the dad
comes out in the scrubs sure and it's
this thing and they were like you can't
go out into the waiting room with those
scrubs on I wonder why I like what germs
are saying had to put my jeans and my
Ultimate Warrior t-shirt back on oh no I
was like I'm announcing the birth with
my Ultimate Warrior t-shirt on like this
suddenly felt like an ass didn't you
yeah I did this is silly um but they
were all like oh are we going in I was
like no I want everything's good
everyone's healthy you all need to just
wait out here you can go home if you
want none of them they didn't leave none
of them they stay your mom stayed all of
them stayed every last one of them
stayed and I was like oh gu it's like
and also when are you going to tell Jess
like I didn't know when to like let her
know like okay we do have guests like
she's trying to recover from like a day
she might as well have had her ankles
tied up and just get dragged around by a
truck for three hours you know what I
mean she was in no shape and she and I
like at some point I have to be like so
when should we bring the guests in so
wait after the after they show her up
and stuff they they take the kid
obviously you're not walking around with
the baby where where no the baby stays
in uh in the surgery room and they
that's they they they clean it up there
they have a station for it and Jess gets
cleaned up and and the whole thing
happens and then there's a recovery room
so now we're we've been in the delivery
room all day we're out of the delivery
room we go into the surgery room we go
out of the surgery room we're in this
recovery room that's just like small and
blah blah blah and uh so is the baby
with you there they brought Jess in they
brought the baby in yep and then the
baby could stay with us in the uh in the
recovery room which was great and like
you know you hang out with the baby and
blah blah blah and uh he's all hooked up
to stuff no baby did not need to be
hooked up to anything NOP he was
perfectly like he didn't need to be they
they checked him they didn't need to
bring him into the uh
NICU they didn't need to do oh no the
what
and I see yeah you and I see
you oh no oh no they
know there's no comment in
there so so no they didn't need to do
any of that stuff like he was he was
ready to go he came out snipped the deal
the the umbilical cord they pinched it
off with the clip and he's he's cleaned
him off and they swaddled him and he's
ready to go they like being like wrapped
up tightly in that age don't they
swaddled yeah because especially this
kid I mean he was he had no room to move
in the womb so they're used to that warm
like you know tight thing what' you say
to him when you first saw him uh
probably hey buddy I don't remember I
guess probably hey buddy something like
that but I think that's the same thing I
say to my dog so I don't know if that's
appropriate well that's what are you
going to say yeah I know like what are
you going to plus he's not going to talk
back so no not at all but uh uh like
who's this weirder with the lady voice
yeah why you talking to me like that um
so Jess is uh uh Jess is now in the
recovery room the baby's there there's
[__] 200 there's a family reunion
going on in the waiting room and and I'm
like you know we're going to be here
because the thing about getting a
C-section is you got to be in the
hospital for 4 days oh wow they keep you
longer cuz you know you can't it's a
surgery and you can't move around
like she's like today's goal is that
just walks around a little bit
yesterday's goal was that she could go
to the bathroom you know what I mean
like it's like it's a slow progression
she had a catheter in I was like you
sure you want to get that luxury removed
yeah just show out and just have a piss
bag next to her bed that somebody else
had to clean
up yeah you kept the placenta what you
do with the piss
bag we saved that for you absolutely
yeah Uncle Jimmy get gets the piss
bag so she's that's Jim's lunch bag you
know how like when you're in high school
that's his brown paper bag just to keep
me warm if I'm
cold yeah it's a hot pack he wears it
like you know you know those uh those
things that you keep in your pockets
that you hold during cold days Jim has
two bags full of piss yeah you bring
them to the Giants
game one pro so you're uh so she's still
in the hospital now and the baby's with
her baby's with her and I'm in there
with her and like uh you do skin to skin
is a thing I guess where I never I
didn't know about this but like where in
order like the Mom feels like to get
closer like you put the baby on just
baby skin on Mom's skin and whatever
like Jess kept telling me like even all
day yesterday she was like don't forget
to do skin to skin I'm like I'm not you
got to do skin to skin I mean at some
point it I've suggested it here in the
radio
Studio Jim Norton and Sam Robert should
be a skin- to skin show skin to skin
right if we're going to be coomes we
need to do skin to skin everybody Travis
and Adrian just ass cheeks to ass cheeks
little skin to skin bonding dbag and hot
dog need to do skin to skin I don't
disagree yeah I think so hey Travis so
far Sam's describing is this kind of
what your experience was more or less
yeah yeah did you did you watch it no I
no they rushed her in real quick cuz I
don't know you know what you like
actually I just remembered what I said
to her while the surgery was going on
cuz I looked at the curtain and I looked
around and I was like I was like
hey Jess she was like yeah I was like
remember that episode of Seinfeld where
Kramer starts going to watch surgeries
and she was like she was like yeah and I
was like remember the Junior Mints
they're very delicious and the
anesthesiologist just bends over and he
goes oh the junior mint episode oh that
was that was classic that was classic
see it would have been a fun time just
bunch of people talking Seinfeld sure
yeah we're talking about as her stomach
is getting like opened up we're talking
about when Kramer dropped a junior Min
into somebody's stomach meanwhile you
should have been talking about his Laugh
Factory setting yeah that's how great
would have been if I looked up at the
anesthesiologist and I was like yeah you
hear what else he said you think that's
good wait to see a
standup um so yeah so she's doing skin
to skin and then uh they immediately she
immediately starts trying to feed the
baby you know breastfeed the baby sure
uh the kid just knows right yeah I mean
you got to you got to kind of guide it a
little bit and teach it how to do it
right and and all that but it's it's
it's not it's not like it's a foreign
concept to right but uh yeah but that
takes a while you know and like I'm like
Jess that's why I was like we got all
these like people outside you know what
do you want to do and she was
like was she happy to have them all in
well no I mean she like she loves them
but no who wants at that moment yeah she
want company can you imagine like you
know you're just like every private
orifice of your your body has just been
like like you just your body is
basically just a medical tool at that
point like you have no energy left for
modesty right and like you have to deal
with these people who are just not in
the same head space sure that are going
to see you at dinner in two weeks and be
like Oh remember when uh your leg was
over there and like you just don't you
don't need it you know um but you know
everybody wants to meet the kid are they
allowed to touch the baby that early or
no is are they afraid of germs that that
soon they are allowed they I the
hospital was like the only people who
can't visit are people who are sick but
they don't like test you they just take
your word for it but they're not like I
mean it's up to the parents consent and
like we weren't going to pass the baby
around that night like it wasn't Jess
was holding on to the baby and
rightfully so did people come over and
touch the baby or or did the little
scratch like the on the shoulder in the
back yeah they did like yeah and so I
ended up uh bringing people in one at a
time oh good who was first I've let I'm
gonna guess Jess's mother yeah but not
all the mothers thought that that was
necessarily the de all of a sudden as as
as the mother's walking in and the door
is closed and they hear from outside
well it was Samy's come the door
closes yeah I I had to remind her I was
like Mom when your daughter gave birth
like you were given the priority and she
was like well nobody else came when she
gave birth she felt like because there
were all these people cuz you know my
sister's husband his family's from
Boston so they didn't come they weren't
there the
moment the birthing happened mother was
a little upset with they were there at
appropriate hours yeah in the moment in
the moment she felt like maybe she
should be able to go in and see her her
grandson first but or Tai or yes or some
kind of tie situation but I was like no
I mean I think I think I think Jess will
and I let her mom stay in the whole time
because I think Jess will want to see
her mom you know what I mean it's it was
more for Jess yeah good move picking
favorites but then so I let people come
in one at a time should have made your
mom wait till last I did did you well
because it's Jess's family oh I see so
it's like you know I wanted I wanted to
let Jess's family come in first and so
her dad came in and then he left and
then her sister came in and he left and
then and then but I mean her sister's
boyfriend was there I was like like Jess
is feeding so you can't come he's like
yeah I guess that makes sense but I'm
like you like like she's been da him
like he's a good guy but she's been
dating him for like eight months or
however long I don't know how long like
absolutely like Jess's like yeah titties
are out so she could feed absolutely if
your if your radio show co-host and
friends can't come in he can't come in
no free pece fair is fair everybody's
trying to absolutely yeah when's feeding
time I need to visit just yeah so your
mom and your dad came in together yeah
everybody came in and my Mom and Dad
yeah they got to come in together and
everybody spent some time and you know
gave the baby a little kiss on the
forehead and and d and uh and did the
whole thing and then and we were there
for like and then you know we got them
out I said Jess's mom out I got
everybody home got to sh everybody away
yeah finally and uh and and so uh uh we
were probably in the recovery room for
like an hour and like Jess was not doing
well with the drugs like she was
freaking out she just want like she just
wanted to not be on drugs she's a bummer
high like she's wrecked everybody else's
fun yeah like you know that like when
somebody gets high and then they don't
want to be high yeah yeah yeah that was
where she was at like she just didn't
want to be on drugs but then they had to
give her more drugs because they had to
massage her stomach to put every make
sure everything was kind of falling into
place oh that's what they do to make
sure it's all back in the right order
huh yeah and her stomach was hurting
from the result of it being completely
open up tender yeah yeah so they had to
give her more drugs and then she was
like she and plus she'd been up all
night she just gone through Labor and
surgery like when did she finally
sleep she F like we finally got back to
the the room room that that we're in
still now at like uh
1130 almost midnight wow I ordered some
diner food she couldn't eat of course
doesn't mean I can't eat though
absolutely you should yeah yeah so I
ordered uh I ordered delivery what'd you
have
chicken fingers good boy how you treat
yourself got some too yeah celebrate a
little bit do you want to take a few
congratulations people really want to
say hello and congratulate you and yeah
sure um couple of people commenting on
things we've talked about already people
are very happy for you the phones are
lit it's very very nice um hi Chris in
Memphis how are you good how are you
guys I'm
Good Good Sam congratulations man it's a
it's a it's an awesome ride thanks buddy
I've got three kids myself and we had uh
C-sections with all three and and and
for those by the way for those that
think that anything's going to change on
the show not a little bit not much I
have uh I did tell Jim that actually
like it was weird on Sunday night I
stopped thinking Uncle Paul was funny
and I don't know how that but I was like
but you wouldn't understand Jim yeah I
sure wouldn't stop but I I just don't
unfortunately so you'll never when's
Milo's book coming out
he's got good
tips yeah when you become a parent Uncle
Paul becomes a little more uncomfortable
well you know what here's the thing the
fact that uh uh anybody would think that
Uncle Paul was at all comfortable like
you don't have to have kids to realize
that pedophilia is not the greatest
thing in the world creep I think I'll
still probably look at Uncle Paul
exactly the same way with utter contempt
disgust AB absolutely and with a fond
memory so you're wife had three
C-sections yeah yeah we had C-sections
all three and uh they they instruct you
not to look over that that tarp but I'm
I'm pretty tall so I can kind of see
over it and the way the last hospital
was set up I didn't look over for the
first two but the way the last hospital
was set up they had the the station for
the baby across the room so you had to
actually walk in front of the tarp and
across the room to get to the baby oh
Jesus Christ that's terrible positioning
yeah it was it was it was God awful like
they positioned us so like we were
sitting there and to my left like Jess's
body is in front of me obviously and the
baby position is to my left so I could
literally just walk back and forth from
the baby position to Jess with no risk
of seeing anything unless I specifically
you know cocked my head over well sir
did you look oh yeah that's that's a
much better setup yeah well you kind of
you don't want to but then you're you're
kind of walking over there and you're
like oh hey and you kind of look over
and it is
it's a [__] mess man yeah I can only
I can like there was like when I was
leaving the room out of the corner of my
eye I could
see like stuff like blood and stuff and
then as I was leaving there was just
like a ton of bloody Rags like against
the wall that were all and I was like I
don't even I this is barbaric what's
happening people in the medical
profession are pretty amazing thank you
thank you for the call Chris I
appreciate
people are really all right buddy people
people are amazing that they can do that
for a living I could see I could see
even in like even in the SL like the
anesthesiologist like when he was doing
the uh the what's it called in the back
epidural the epidural uh I could see in
his eyes like he was
concentrating to a level like she was so
laser focused the anesthesiologist just
the anesthesiologist on exactly what he
was doing to make sure the epidural hit
the right spot so he didn't have to to
redo anything so nothing [__] up
because it's one of those things where
it could be dangerous but it's almost
always not but it's because to do that
you have to be so laser focused so I can
only imagine the type of concentration
and focus that you need to have I think
my uncle marks an anesthesiologist and
yeah you you just got to to be a surgeon
you got two lives in your hands yes
[__] it's a lot of pressure but
doctors like it though like they they
like our doctor he wasn't even on call
like he came in on his day off to
deliver the baby because I think you
know they they like cuz it's the same
doctor that had to tell us two years ago
you oh the bad news yeah you don't need
to get your hearing check folks there's
nothing to see here wow you know what I
mean it's so like I hope he didn't say
it like that that's exactly what he said
no so the fact that like he has to give
shitty news I think that doctors that
work in that field like really get off
on getting to deliver a healthy they
want to be the hero too like I had to
give you some [__] news but look it
worked out it wasn't meant to be right
and uh jarn and Kansas had something
similar with the family hi jarn or is it
Jaren CH [__]
yeah yeah when I my wife and I had our
first or our second baby uh she had a
C-section all that stuff and they were
giving her pain pills and she got
constipated you're supposed to when you
get those pain pills you have to give
stool softeners all that well anyways
her whole family everybody well
grandparents wanted to come up and Laura
said she didn't want them so I said had
to talk to a 70-year-old woman that tell
her that she could not come in the room
to see her great-grandson
wow horrifying Sam horrifying why now
why didn't she want them up
there uh well she hadn't slept in about
18 hours uh she hadn't [__] in probably
two and a half days she was just
completely uncomfortable yeah so and and
you know their big thing was is they
wanted to take care of their gr she's
diabetic as well type one diabetic so
immune system everything sucks well
that's that's the thing of like like you
see like in a movie you know the baby
comes out and then everybody's kind of
smiling and it was like oh man labor was
so intense but now everything's happy
bring everyone in but what really
happens is like the the the woman I
can't imagine the feeling that a woman
must go through when they get pregnant
again quickly because like I could see
getting pregnant again but that's after
you experience some of the good stuff
with the baby like watching what Jess
went through on Sunday night like I
would never wish that on my worst enemy
like that it's you know the end is
awesome but everything leading up to the
end is like awful and the most
uncomfortable I've ever seen a person
but like like but like stress that they
have is outrageous yeah yeah but then
everybody wants to come in and like but
it's also like people come in like I
want one guy's going in he's like uh so'
you get the epidural J's like yeah and
he was like yeah I would have
recommended that it hurts a lot more if
you don't B and I'm like very smart
commentary like like just some [__]
expert he's a man talking about as if he
were pregnant like how the [__] would
you know what an epidural even feels
like and he's like like so you have like
experts coming in and you have people
giving their unwanted opinions on stuff
or like you just had the baby and
they're like so what are you going to do
about the dog now I mean isn't it going
to be tough to walk the dog you just had
a C-section and she's like I found out I
was getting a C-section 90 minutes ago
so people don't know what to say and
they just say stupid [__] awful a still
have your hospital bracelet thank thank
you very much for the call jarn
appreciate oh what happened with the
grandmother what'd she
do huh what happened with the
grandmother uh it actually that was
about the first day that I kind of took
over my own family where I was kind of
the protector and I think it was like a
passing of the torch to where I had to
stand up for my wife and you know my
family and they all kind of just took a
little step back but it was bad for a
couple months it is weird thank you very
much that is what happens though like I
took Jess's phone away and I started
answering her text messages and like oh
I hope you [__] up a few friendships
and and like saying like like telling
people even yesterday like putting
people on a schedule and being like you
can't come now you can come then you
can't come blah blah blah like just you
know making sure and I mean and we still
had people popping in that weren't
didn't even tell us they were coming
like we people don't know what the
protocol is I know and they're being
they're trying it's tough cuz they're
trying to be nice you know and they're
trying to just be a part of it but I'm
like just let us know and I'll tell you
did you tell anyone did you turn anyone
away uh I mean I turned a couple people
away that that first night I turned the
boyfriend away you know the stepdad
stayed outside but that was kind of his
own choice anyway but I did uh I did
hold people stepdad didn't go in and see
her no cuz she was like she was just in
a state and she was feeding and it was
it was fine he he'll probably stop by at
some point today or something but uh uh
yeah no I I I I held people I've been
holding people back a lot yeah like go
like hang out in the lobby you can go
home if you want come back in an hour or
like I'll text somebody and be like hey
I know he said 12:30 Jesse is going to
nap for a while come by in an hour come
by in 4 take care yeah um a fair
question here uh Mike uh New York Mike
New Mexico we wanted to congratulate you
hello sir hey good morning gentlemen
good morning first I want to say
something to you Jim and then I want to
congratulate Sam but the first thing is
let's get business uh my si uh my sister
her [__] lip increased another inch in
size so about 3 months it should should
be about 9 in Long she'll have a nice
mess for you down there all right thank
you very much I forgot about that this
is the guy whose sister is putting uh
weights on her on her lips for you he
told you he's going to make his sister I
appreciate that put weights on her Leia
for you you're a good man anything
anything for you Jim Sam congratulations
oh thank you I remember I remember when
you first came on a scene on Jim Norton
and Opie and Anthony show and there was
always a question mark about your
ethnicity ethnicity so I'm gon to ask a
question that many of us are wondering
what color is your son he is a a
Caucasian son he's a Caucasian boy I
mean he's he's he's a big he's a big
fella and he does appear I mean you know
it's it's newborn here so who knows he I
mean he looks a lot like uh dag which
has giving me cause for concern it's
true but he's taller yeah he is but but
uh it looks like you might have curly
hair I don't know for sure though okay
well well go congratulations Sam I want
I want the best for you and everything
so now you got all that uh growing up
and teaching your son how to eat [__]
and all that stuff when he gets old I
mean he's got a couple years before I
there's a couple lessons before that's
not probably not uh uh first first grade
but we can we'll get there thank you for
the call very important question thank
you thank you for saying what need to be
said all right and Chris the teacher has
a very important question hi Chris oh
good
good morning boys first of all the
biggest congratulations of all Jim
Norton congratulations performing at the
benefit tonight can't wait to see thank
you very much it's about time we got
back to me yeah no uh nice
congratulations for our pal Sam no yeah
yes yes and uh it's the worse that you
have to deal with the [__] even after
you give birth you still got to deal
with the family dynamics of people
showing up and and and and and and the
moms kind of like uh you know indirectly
fighting with each other are they yeah
about what they just you know they're
both I don't I don't know nothing
nothing yeah they're both thinking the
other ones whatever but like not
actually F they're not saying anything
to each other they're not saying
anything specifically negative about
each other but they're just that sort of
you know that little you know they just
have a Vibe about each other that I'm
like just both of you
relax like that yeah yeah see this is
where our experien is just that hold on
Travis what's that Travis this is where
our experiences you know don't match up
the similarities yeah yeah Travis
Travis's mom and mother-in-law fighting
was like a tumble weed going
by it might as well have been that uh uh
that that that ultrasound two years ago
for me just hearing nothing no fight to
be had Travis wrote a country song about
it called an empty chair in the weding
room yeah Travis's mom was sitting in
that chair that Clint Eastwood was
arguing with at the
RNC were you bummed out at that time
Travis like did it hit you like uh I
honestly I don't even think I thought
about it oh good yeah dude you were and
you didn't have to deal with it yeah and
I didn't have to deal with it great
yeah all right thank you Chris oh you
want oh you had a question oh wait yeah
Sam and most importantly you it had to
be on your mind the doctor that delivers
your son uh has to perform the
circumcision so did you watch did you
give pointers did you show them yours to
make sure what not to do I did no no
mine is good now I'll show him mine and
be like this is what I want but uh no I
think he's going to do it today he said
he said
he said he's going to give the guy
because you know we have to be at the
hospital for a few days because of the
C-section so he said he's going to give
he's going to give him uh a couple of
days to chill and then you appre Jim
you'll appreciate this bomb when the uh
doctor was talking to us about
performing our kids circumcision I tried
to make a joke for levity and I said
well before I give you the job do you
have any you know photos or
work like a tattoo artist just absolute
[__]
Sil that's funny J thanks buddy I'll see
you tonight see hey bye bye all right
pal um
wow yeah so the kids in for a rough day
did they totally numb him for that yeah
and trust me I mean he's in for a rough
day now but it's it's a lot less rough
than if he did it later you think so
yeah I know
so did you guys debate leaving him
circumcised or is like got no no no no
not I mean leaving him uncircumcised
yeah yeah yeah no no no there is no he's
got to be cut yeah definitely let's see
here uh oh wow this is a good point
maybe this is the problem I don't know
anything about the babies but Matt in
California comment
Matt how you guys doing good
buddy good hey so one of the reasons I
think that they pushed for the C-section
so much is um when the baby gets full
term it does a tendency to take a [__]
inside of the placenta that's true and
then you worry about the baby just
inhaling all that [__] into his lungs
that's true he need to get the baby out
as quick as possible so that the
respiratory therapist and the nurses can
get all that it's called meconium get it
all out of there oh wow that's true they
they have to check that when they do
like the uh when they when they get to
that point when it's over and they're
doing fullon ultrasounds they have to
check for how much of that stuff is is
floating around if any because if there
is stuff floating around then then he's
right they have to get it out right away
so they basically that's probably what
was happening when they're like look we
have to do the C-section the kid's
pinching a loaf he's got his hand coming
out for the
newspaper trust me I've seen white
babies come out totally covered in brown
before so it's not good but then it
seizes up their lungs and you get a
whole bunch of diseases and whatnot from
it but it's usually
fixable yeah everybody didn't [__] all
over himself thanks very much luckily
little baby Edgar well
that's I I don't know if that's
necessarily the name we're going to go
with I think that's the name you should
go with you think so little Edgar l l
apostrophe i l Edgar little Edgar oh
what a [__] disaster though last
night was I felt like I was a I I was
just in a wacky Steve Gutenberg movie
when I had changed a diaper oh my God
your first one yeah and it was like you
like that well I didn't even think about
changing a diaper until I was like I we
probably I guess in my mind I was like
probably don't have to do that for a
couple days like you know what I mean
like we're not really in the in the mix
of things yet but the the nurse came in
and she was like have you changed his
diaper yet and I was like no already a
negligent father yeah nobody told me to
just be like nobody told me to do it so
she's like you know no you just kind of
have to you do that now you pick them up
and smell them the parents do that all
the time they pick the kid up and smell
it well so she was like she made it seem
so easy she was like this is what you do
and she did the thing and she undid the
thing and picked it up by its ankles
andan cleaned it off and and and wiped
it clean little wet yeah get the wet
wipe on everything's good put the diaper
back on Snap Snap good to go you know
she was like and you know you got to go
quickly and and watch this because when
uh when he gets cold he pees that's why
babies pee on you cuz when they get cold
they piss to make themselves warm I I
don't know but that's what that's just
what happens so it's like okay no
problem I got this now I know the secret
I'm not going to get pissed on and so
like like yesterday uh Jess was in the
shower so it was just me and I was like
all right I I'm going to go check this
baby's diaper in the hospital in the
hospital yeah and so I was like you know
I'm I'm in charge here so let me just
check this out and like cuz you fig you
get credit for checking until I check
this diaper he's fine or or even like or
even because I saw the nurse do it like
I can easily do that and then Jess is
going to come out like oh my God you did
that without anybody asking you or
anything and it's perfect what a big boy
oh yeah so like uh uh there they put
baby on this table that has drawers in
it and the drawers have extra diapers
extra swaddles you know extra everything
extra onesies the whole deal and so uh
uh I'm like all right let's check your
diaper and I undo the thing and I lifted
him up and he needed a change you need
it was a [__] diaper and so I was like
okay no problem and I started wiping and
it was like it was a little tougher to
get off than it seemed like when the
nurse did it yeah it's like oh and so I
had to like you know scrub a little bit
and then he starts crying cuz babies do
that
and but I'm getting all the nooks and
crannies and he's crying and Jess is
like is everything okay because he
hasn't really cried that much he's a
newborn yeah and I'm like yep
everything's good and like and I'm
having way more trouble than I thought
cleaning like it's taking way too long
and like I'm going through like four wet
wipes or something like I'm obviously
like I'm just making a pile of them and
then I'm like okay uh uh and I bend down
and I'm still I'm holding him up by his
ankles and he keeps like kicking his
feet out so then he falls back down I'm
like no no no no no and holding up his
ankles and then I get the dier on and I
put it on him and I realize it's
backwards like who makes a backwards
diaper mistake so like I take the diaper
off so it's not backwards and then I
start feeling my arm is warm and I'm
like he's pissing all over me so he's
he's pissing on me there's [__] over
here the [__] diaper is on top of here
I'm also trying to keep everything
separate CU I don't know where things go
but I know he shouldn't have like a
bunch of shitty stuff on so I'm I put it
on towels but I realized those are clean
towels so you can't put [__] diapers on
clean towels then there's [__] on the
towels that's a great name for a book by
the way can't put [__] diapers on clean
towels yeah and I'm holding him and I
got pissed all over me and then I look
at him and he's got pissed all over his
onesie now because he pissed on me and
him and I'm like God damn it and now
he's just
like and I'm like ah and Jess's like are
you okay I go yeah I'm changing a diaper
and so then I get this diaper that I put
on backwards and I put it on him and I'm
like H and it's got like straps that are
kind of like Vel it's not like sticky
things and so I put it on him and I'm
like okay I think he's good and I
realized that the velcro is just over
his flesh it's not even on the diaper
and I'm like no it's just a corner of it
so I take it off and then you can't put
it retick it after you stick it so I'm
like ah [__] so I have to take off that
diaper and try to stop him from pissing
and he's like in tears and hysterics now
CU now I have to like I'm holding him
with one hand with by the ankles and
then I'm trying to get a diaper out of
the drawer like down here and so then I
have to pull it out and like put another
new diaper on him I got that on him but
he's [__] freezing cold now because
he's just been naked and I had to take
his onesie off because there's piss all
over it and then his swaddle had piss
all over it so I had to put him on the
bed and like just put sheets around him
and then get a bunch of swaddles because
then I looked at the at the crib that he
was in the like the hospital bed thing
that the little thing that he's in the
plastic thing right and like it's not
the piss isn't just on his swaddle sure
it it bled through so it's on the liner
of the thing like it's on everything and
so I had to take that and put it down
and then I resaddled him and wrapped him
up real TW real tight and then I had to
strip this thing the crib thing that he
was in and raddle all that stuff and
then just put him down and like Jess
comes out and she goes is everything
okay and I go and he's like now he's
quiet and he's all swaddled but he he
looks like he's quiet cuz he just went
through a traumatic experience like he's
like I don't know what the [__] that was
but I'm never [__] again and and so
he's laying there and uh I go yeah
everything's fine but that's what it
took to change a diaper and there is
just this massive pile of soiled Linens
like it's it's a onesie it's like three
swaddles it's all this stuff and like we
went through all all the the the
swaddles we went through the onesie we
went through two diapers we went through
everything and I'm like there it all is
and and then the N the woman who clean
stuff comes in she goes I think you want
me to get rid of this right and I was
like Jess do we get rid of the onesie
even though that was his first onesie
and she was like there's piss all over
it and I was like oh oh I guess that's
why like when parents have stuff they're
like this is the thing that he came home
in they're never like this is the first
thing right cuz there's piss on there's
piss all over it and then I had to take
my hoodie and like try to wash it in the
sink cuz they just piss on the sleeve
like you know there's it's one thing to
smell like a baby like babies smell
amazing baby's smell is [__] so cute
but baby piss smells like piss yes it
does it's just it just smells like piss
on my hood does he have that little
smell on his face that little cute baby
cheek smell
yes yes yeah nature is so [__] smart
cuz that makes you want to be nice to
the kid yeah makes you want to take care
of them then I don't know what the
hospital is doing but the towels smell
like babies too that's such a cool smell
yeah yeah they wash them with babies
they do right they throw yeah they have
to take a baby and throw it in the dryer
and he tumble dries with the kitten what
the [__] that's what happens with all
those placentas I can answer the
question Kyle in Alabama what's the
baby's name it's Edgar Edgar yeah I was
going to go with uh my
Undertaker but uh Undertaker Roberts I
thought was a strong name but I guess
it's Lil Edgar yeah if it was a girl I
was thinking Lyla
Chipeta wait you want me to name it
after my dog and you I was thinking that
no Lyle as a girl oh cuz the dog's name
is Lyla oh no no Lyall I was thinking
Lyle
lla Chipeta yeah Roberts but Edgar's
nice I'm honored in a weird way yeah
little Edgar edgi is what we call him
well that's I am I supposed to get Sam a
gift I was thinking of that too I should
probably get you guys a gift right I
should guess I don't have protocol we
yeah everybody just uh cash will do yeah
I fig some money well just do money huh
yeah everybody uh maybe I'll get your
can of blue paint for the baby room yeah
that's good yeah we got to find a place
that has a another
room you do baby doesn't have a room
right now so you got to move he's got an
area you know but he doesn't he's got
like an area that's big enough for a
baby I'm not watching him I'm not asking
you to watch them so you got to get like
a place for the either a bigger master
or yeah I'll either get another bedroom
apartment or would just you know bite
the bullet and get a house so you
thinking about him all the time yeah you
had a baby yeah yeah it's weird like do
you feel different I don't feel
different as a person like I feel like
my weekend was more important than any
body else's you know like I was watching
like like I was looking at like Roland's
Instagram for instance and like and like
normally like and he had like one of his
food weekends and like normally I'd be
like oh that's that's awesome like he
went to all these restaurants and it
just seems like a fun time but like I
had this thought like my weekend was way
more important than a food weekend or
like and I'm not picking on Rong like
any Instagram like rck like he's like
you know hey this is the iced tea I'm
drinking today and I'm like yeah what I
got going on is way more important than
that and you were right or the fact that
I got totally stood up on a date it it's
one of those things your weekend is ABS
I probably still want to explore that a
no need to and I mean really stood up oh
no no I'm so glad you didn't tell me in
advance yeah I want to know about that
well no no this is baby today um but we
I I want to I want to take a leak and uh
we'll come back we'll talk more about
Sam we had calls coming in by the way
Roland just texted me and he said have
you tried the hot dog like Ran's like I
don't think you understand how important
my food weekend was I'm happy
congratulations but I'm happy that the
baby is healthy and and Jess is good and
But to answer your question about
thinking about I'm like it's so weird
that uh uh
before like it was like I all I just
wanted him to come out and be safe
because once he's out of the womb it's
like now he's safe now he's a person and
he's safe but like that doesn't I don't
think that ever goes away like I think
like when he's 30 I'm going to be like
oh I hope he doesn't get into a car
accident and die you know what I mean I
just think it's just kind of something
that you just is always there it's a
whole not for
everyone now some people just totally
stop thinking like that yeah after like
21 years yeah some people like maybe
they think about it for a while yeah
yeah yeah but once you're an adult they
don't they don't think about that too
muchmore yeah then they're like you know
what I'm done yeah if he's 16 and he has
hair like Laura D and he's holding a cat
in a sweater you're going be like I'm
I'm out of here so so you're saying some
some parents do have a tap out moment
yeah yeah yeah I mean it can happen Okay
so we don't know could 50/50 you know
what then all I'm going to do is speak
for today absolutely all I'm going to do
is speak for today and let tomorrow
bring what it brings you know maybe
tomorrow I'll meet a nice Jewish
man and leave everyone leave all of you
do skin- to skin with
him what a good what a good weekend man
for you oh but and and I felt like such
a a a a a neglectful person like I
thought all the nurses were judging me
cuz you know at the hospital they have
this chair that F it's like a a a fold
out couch but it's just a chair but it
folds out into a fulllength bed and it's
not bad you know right you know it's
really like I've slept on it the last
two nights and I'd perfectly fine sleep
but uh like that first night I was so
exhausted because I'd also been up all
night with Jess and I had napped or
anything that like we got back to the
room and well even when you're in the
hospital like the baby sleeps in a
nursery it doesn't sleep in your room
the first night or two but we still like
I guess you don't have to but especially
if you're breastfeeding like they bring
the baby in every 3 or four hours
regardless you're not getting eight
hours of sleep like the baby's going to
come in and
feed at probably twice during the night
um I didn't wake up at all the first
night like there were like a whole bunch
of nurses came in the baby came in Jess
was awake feeding I slept through all of
it that's important I'm glad you slept
through glad you got your rest all of it
like I could I can't imagine and what
those nurses must have been thinking
like dad doesn't want to doesn't want to
he's just going to he just sleep in I
was so tired yeah well you had a day
yeah tuckered out I was I was all
tuckered out you tuckered out you had to
by the way you Sam texted me and he told
me that she had birth and everything was
okay and we were talking and uh and he
goes yeah yeah she gave birth last night
uh I I can come in Monday Tuesday
Tuesday I'm like okay but you know if
you want to take a couple days you're
welcome to do that yeah I mean you know
you can yeah I don't who I mean look if
I need to maybe when she leaves the
hospital if I need to if she needs the
support then yeah but it's like just
just know you can and your you know your
spots here no no I okay I appreciate it
but I also like you know you're not
supposed to I'm not you know you can't
like uh you got to set an example and
you can't if you start early living your
life just specifically like around this
baby you end up you know with a little
like sick baby dag you know what I mean
like and there is a balance though I
would I would imagine that that sick
baby has really really great parents cuz
he's a great kid and he works really
hard but something tells me that his dad
took the full paternity leave you know
what I mean like that's to take care of
him yeah yeah and that's a great thing
that's not my my my choice I probably
there's not a lot going on yeah I know
because Jess is feeding like just
keeping it alive right that's all that's
going on like if if if and and yeah she
got a C-section so it's a little tougher
to move around sure so like but you know
because your wife got a C-section right
so like if she needs the hand then I
will but if it's I mean it's just for
the morning I'm going to drive back to
the hospital after the show
okay [__] it's awesome yeah it's fun
really awesome yeah GL she's healthy and
everything is good but I'm honestly like
in the
moment maybe equally as happy that you
got stood up so and then man that's just
that's just that's just the moment two
good things in a weekend I mean Travis
great things the word is great yeah like
like you're happy two things that that I
want to tell my entire family about like
two things that I want to share the
information you think that's good news
oh it's great news yeah it's the best
news horribly um and and I guess we
could we come back we could talk more
Sam is the theme of we'll talk all about
this this is going to be an ongoing
thing and uh yeah we'll touch on Milo
today too that's I'd like and and there
was a lot I got some very funny tweets
over the weekend uh uh before all this
happened from people that said they
heard me tease the new show that's
coming to the channel faction talk but I
hadn't said what it was and you know
some people were excited some people
were pissed some people think it's you
know Jason Alice and his uh and his
tyranny run a muck over the leading this
channel into into whatever um
uh so we should probably play the promo
oh you did talk that's right I said
there was a new show coming what's
congratulations Denny just give a hug
Denny touching me give him a hug
congratulations P congratulations Denny
just walked in you giving out cigars no
I'm not giving out cigar oh yeah are you
supposed to give out cigars was I
supposed to do that I was right cigars
are nice Travis did you give out cigars
no I got a cigar in my pants if you want
to smoke it that's that's what I said to
everybody
good he's sitting
down cool welcome oh sorry oh did you
forget to turn on Denny's mic all right
sorry welcome aboy give me some juice
congratulations give you some juice
juice oh sorry he said that too fast
bring some of those juw in here and I'm
and I'm proud of you that you're here uh
working because I was working the day
that my wife had a C-section too and
during the conception you
were she had the baby on the overnight
and I called up the general manager I
said look my uh my wife just had a baby
he goes good the motion meeting is at
9:00 today I said I'll be there yeah he
did Denny told me that before uh and you
know Denny is my inspiration for life so
he told me that before he said that uh
that his wife kind of had the baby like
super quick like it wasn't the story
like mine it was it was she started
going into labor at noon and at 4 the
baby was born second though right yeah
second the third she was all nice stred
out she said if the first one was a
C-section she wouldn't have anymore CU
it's it's it's a lot of lot of work but
uh he said that they couldn't his boss
told him they couldn't cover his shift
Jes well I had a gig I had a gig that
night and I was getting dressed and I
had the tuxedo on to host a show that
night and I tried calling guys I got I
got tickets he had a DJ tux on when his
kid was born God so I walk in and they
give you the scrubs so I put the scrubs
on over the tuxedo and after the baby's
born I said all right everything looks
good here you know what else could I do
you know right right you know like the
doctor said do you know do you want to
cut the cord I said no I'll leave that
up to you I said you know I don't yeah I
go I don't let you handle the mixes when
I'm doing a party I said so I'm not
going to let you drop did they ask you
do you want to cut too bad you didn't
write Cats in the Cradle Denny and he
said I'm going to be nothing like
him so I so I go do the gig gigs over
like at midnight I go back to the
hospital I walking with a tuxedo they
probably thought it was like James Bond
or something yeah they probably thought
something besides that no M yeah yeah
tuxedo with [__] balloon animals in
the pocket so I brought pastries into
work the next day that's nice yeah
instead of cigars yeah pastes better
more fun because uh the women you can't
give the woman a cigar sure you can
right [__] like a little pastry little
pastry it put it in there yeah I went to
the to the sporting goods store brought
my son a baseball bat and a glove the
next day you know please don't be gay
please don't be gay
day so congratulations and uh very happy
we have a new show coming to the channel
what's that I that Sam telling me about
it right now he's promoting he knows
Jason better than I do so he's promoting
it should we play it now or when we get
back what do you want it's a promo do
you want to play it as we go on a break
or do you want to no cuz we want to
commentate on it okay well then we come
back okay we'll be right back uh
congratulations to Sam and Jess band new
uh brand new baby boy 9B 3 o Edgar
little baby Edgar Jess is doing well the
baby's doing well the kid has gigantic
feet yeah and um Denny is here hooray